do you know there is a degree called um
poultry science no way jack off chickens
no what do you mean jack off chicken I
mean jack off a chicken what do you mean
you just like there's more science than
that to poultry yeah sure but that is
one of the things you learn yeah that's
what you gotta know okay like that's one
of the classes yeah we're jacking off
horses chickens whatever and people I'm
not kidding graduate 250 000 a year
there is so much no one wants to do that
exactly fighting tooth and that's their
job no chickens actually have huge [ __ ]
yeah could we get the picture of this
nice
nice nice thank you very much appreciate
that yeah so much money my wife would be
great at that job
I'll give you that one
we're sitting close now so we can yeah
we can touch mics we can touch tips
my mic doesn't reach
[Laughter]
yeah you gotta you got a short one hold
on you got a short one it's just cold
what was your major
what do you think my major was business
marketing Communications
lib Arts lib Arts lib art lib Arts what
even do you study like how talking yeah
we just just emailing back and forth
yeah just like the way in which we
communicate Right facts no communication
personal intro personal yeah right
what's the difference you wouldn't know
would you
Cody wouldn't because he doesn't
socialize he just uses chat GPT to talk
to everybody
yeah that's that's that's Communications
now
that's the modern day this is so sad
yeah the state of our world no it's sick
actually yeah that's so cool Cody's
every day trying to engineer how to talk
to people less yeah yeah before I came
here I ran I ran this like what could
potentially happen today through chat
gbt oh okay I was like bringing Bros is
coming on what what can I talk to her
about right and what did Chad gbt return
Butler [ __ ] uh poultry science yeah
yeah so chicken jacking yeah isn't it
isn't it crazy that the chicken jacking
guys are making more money than you
isn't that really upsetting I mean it's
awesome they deserve it I think they do
did they only chicken Jack or they Jack
the horse you've okay can we pull a
picture of a horse [ __ ]
have you guys actually seen a picture of
a horse stick let's not do that okay can
we actually get on oh dude
hey could we uh no dude it's past the
first 15 seconds it's fine go ahead
throw it away let's censor it so this is
uh bring up a picture of a horse [ __ ] I
need you to imagine just straight to
YouTube Mr hands I don't think that's on
YouTube dude no it's up there now it's
pretty tame compared to that too long
it's it's Creative Commons now yeah
there's gonna be a day where Mr hands is
Creative Commons
yeah okay yeah okay yeah I see what
you're doing oh this [ __ ] looks like
Elmer fudd's rifle that's crazy
looks like a [ __ ] Civil War boot that
ain't even a dick
that ain't even a dick man I put my
entire arm in a cow's ass he did so what
is the story
that's it awesome we were just driving
and he's like hey look at that we pulled
over and I said you wanna you wanna bet
you wanna stop the car
you want to see something cool yeah no
it was uh we were we were like shooting
this like pilot thing and that was one
of like the yeah the like dares or
whatever like the tasks we were supposed
to do I couldn't do no [ __ ] you really
did I did all the way up to my shoulder
I couldn't get past the smell
and when I and when I slowly took that
[ __ ] out it was just covered there it is
Porky Pig oh yeah my Porky Pig looking
[ __ ] like that
showing that [ __ ] off man you wanna you
you want it eat my ass
Winnie the poohing yeah
finish all over my lower back
awful
bad
sorry anyway so back to you were fisting
account yeah so when you did that was it
rewarding in any sense like okay yeah it
was it was rewarding in the sense where
it was like holy [ __ ] I can't believe I
just did that
conquered I'm sorry I did it you know
I'm not like I'm So Random yeah yeah
exactly yeah yeah lawnmower
okay literally bacon moments
do you have a mustache on your hand okay
literally bacon when you're when your
hand was in there how'd you do were you
like one of those like Amsterdam dildos
where you like like it was like between
things like I was feeling like like
organs or whatever on either side like
it was like two big spheres sort of my
hand was kind of stuck in the middle and
so I started tickling a little bit yeah
no no not like that I just mean like
pickle you know I'm not like
[Laughter]
what's going on
simulator
[Laughter]
they got a Sim rig at home so you can
practice
is that what this is yeah you can hook
that up to a [ __ ] uh farm farm life
simulator imagine winning the Imagine
winning the gulag
well not one time on Call of Duty won
the gulag on a racing Sim yeah you saw
the clip I killed someone with a
steering wheel it like went viral
wherever yeah here we go all right so I
couldn't turn left or right so this guy
I knew he's gonna run past me and then I
I killed him I killed him was the shot
the the no I was shifting up on them
steering wheel now imagine your stream
starts and you're just shoulder deep in
a horse and a horse and you're like all
right boys where are we dropping
all right it's gonna be weird real easy
he's done yo Noel is goaded on the horse
half he's [ __ ] goaded
quick switching
laughs
I know her husband is was just [ __ ]
pelvis deep in this she's like honey are
you are you messing with my work laptop
again I just had to try it sorry sorry
what are you gonna say
I was gonna talk about Rick and Morty so
it's actually not any better than what
you were saying this isn't actually an
episode of Rick and Morty where there's
like a sex robot or something and Morty
like takes it to his room and just like
so many loads in the robot right and
populates a whole planet based off kind
of something like this oh fun yeah so
that's so we're not original okay so you
just had to kill the mood wow Rick and
Morty does just turn you to a redditor
actually Rick and Morty episode okay
actually Dan Harmon actually said that
what's that from Reddit Millennial just
millennials
like
that's good yeah we do make fun of the
redditor Persona yeah all the time but
that like nails it oh yeah that's really
that's just Millennial cringe you guys
know that is yeah yeah what do you mean
what do you mean I'm 22. what are you
talking about
I love you how old do you think I
actually don't answer that okay okay if
you would have said something I would
have been really offended I'm 25 okay
because when you guys came to a m I had
just graduated I also graduated at 21.
is that cool or something yeah cause I'm
a [ __ ] genius
wait what age are you supposed to
graduate at 22 oh really yeah I
graduated at 28. nice nice dude all
right I dropped out at 20. 65 degrees
Yeah you know I minored in Spanish do
you speak Spanish no do I
do you
yeah dude great question do you do you
speak Spanish hablo espanol
Hermano period
was Latino confirmed
anyways um
what do you got a response to that kind
of just dissed you he got your ass good
I did can we go back a couple tabs I'm
gonna show you exactly what it looks
like
is it the horse yeah yeah okay okay
yeah that's a crazy head on that by the
way it is
elephant trunk horses don't give head
I think dolphins do though do they
really yeah some mammals are known to to
BJ really yeah oh look it up what animal
is a [ __ ]
which animals suck that thing yeah
which animal suck am I Johnson till I
come
yeah I'm just gonna put this search on
Luke so he'll get arrested
bro Otto
Otto fellatio oh that's cool what is
auto fellatio to yourself yeah what it
is yeah man just a dolphin swimming in
the [ __ ] Circle
that dolphin just nutted in his own neck
nutted in your blowhole
oh
auto fellatio or oral sex is an animals
is documented in spiders spiders give
head
goats okay gross
okay literally does [ __ ] close
damn seriously okay seriously disgusting
can I see a video